I think we are basically products of a
complex evolutionary story that we don't
fully grasp we're caught debating the
scientists say we are primates the the
religious side says we are children of
God and I think that literally speaking
of course I think the scientists are
right but the scientists are so caught
up in this reductionist approach to
evolution in which we are individuals
who who evolved cooperation through
reciprocity and kinship and that's it
that most scientists now looking at
evolution are very wary of the idea that
actually group level selection shaped us
once you once you see that human groups
have competed with each other for a long
time and you start thinking well what
are the aspects of human nature that
that would lead to success in group
competition you realize in group loyalty
tribalism hierarchy respect I
disappeared in pollution religion these
were crucial in binding us into
cooperative groups this is where I think
religious believers and conservatives
are on to some truths that we secular
liberal scientists have a hard time
accepting their truths nonetheless